So I'm going to read something that
nature road in the first part of beyond
good and evil,
which is a section called the prejudices
of philosophers and it's a really good
example of the dance density.
The of this book,
one of the ways of conceptualizing
beyond good and evil,
and I think this is true for most great
work,
so
it's true [inaudible] works,
is that
the
author of the work
collects unconsciously collects patterns
from his or her interaction with the
world and then give them initial
formulation
and the patterns can be deep and
multilevel.
And the initial formulation translates
them into not so much ideas as into the
seeds of future ideas.
And the more poetic the author happens
to be,
the more the case that his or her
writings contain within it.
The seeds of future ideas and one of the
romantic philosophers are authors and I
think niche industry have ski or are in
some sense foremost among them are
particularly notable.
Further ability to do exactly that.
Now in this particular paragraph,
this particular paragraph not only
serves as an example of that,
but it also serves as the self conscious
reflection on that because Nietzsche is
writing a paragraph here that is full of
the seeds of ideas that will actually
bloom and flower to a great degree in
the 20th century,
but well he cymbalta caneously revealing
these those ideas.
He's also telling you exactly how he's
doing it and how it is that philosophers
do it.
So it's a,
it's a spectacular accomplishment.
I'm going to read it probably phrase by
phrase and then take it apart because
it's so dance and beyond good and evil
is like that.
It's neat you,
when Nisha was writing beyond good and
evil,
he wasn't very well and because of that
he had to spend a lot of time thinking
and not very much time writing and
because he was also brilliant beyond
comprehension,
his ability to distill what he was
thinking into incredibly rich phrases is
I think it's some sense it's beyond
parallel.
I mean often if I'm reading a book,
if it has any utility at all market,
usually I fold over the top of the page
or sometimes put a yellow sticky note on
it too.
If I find a place where there's an idea
that's worth returning to that that's
um,
it's particularly worth understanding.
And you can't do that with a book like
beyond good and evil because what ends
up happening is you have to mark every
sentence and obviously marking every
sentence isn't any better than not
marking any sentences at all.
So
I guess I also might as well tell you
why it is worth bothering with a book
like this at all because it's a very
difficult book and it,
it's also the sort of book that will
rattle you up so neat.
You is,
is very interested in the problem of
value.
And the problem of value fundamentally
is not the problem of what is the world
made out or even how does the world
function,
which are more in some sense more
specifically scientific questions.
But how is it that you should conduct
yourself in the world?
How should you act?
And people act towards aims in a sense
because we're active creatures and we're
moving from one point to another.
We're moving towards things that we
want.
And that means that we're guided by our
desires and we're not only guided by
designers in so as we have individual
desires,
we're guided by the structure that
consists of how those desires are
related to one another.
So for example,
if you have a room full of people,
say a room full of children,
they're active and they're each pursuing
their individual desires.
But at some point they may choose to
organize themselves into a game and if
they organize themselves into a game,
what they're doing for all intents and
purposes is producing a little society,
a little micro society.
And within that micro society they're
deciding what desires will be currently
expressed and how they'll exist in
relationship to one another.
And that means that they can cooperate
without too much conflict and that they
can jointly move towards,
um,
a joint ame without
and,
and gather all the benefits that might
be associated with that.
And that might be the accomplishment of
the Ame,
whatever it is.
But it also might be just the enjoyment
that's to be had in the pursuit of that
activity.
Now people do that
socially because we have to do that in
order to get along with other people
because our designers have to be melded
with those of other people.
But we also do in psychologically.
And those two things exist in a dance
because as I'm interacting with other
people,
the demands of the fact that we're
interacting make require each of us to
arrange our desires in a way that's
acceptable to everyone else.
But at the same time,
what we're doing that we're also
observing the process by which those
desires are ordered.
And then we internalize that process and
use that to order our own desires.
And then so there's a constant
mutually informative dance between the
individual and the group.
And the culmination of that is the
organization of society and the
simultaneous organization of the psyche.
And it's that process that needs you is
talking about in these paragraphs.
Now you might ask yourself,
well,
what's the utility of articulating such
things?
And conceptualizing them and
understanding them and the answer in
some ways,
it's straight forward.
If you don't want to run a foul of the
your own desires,
you have to organize them
because some of them are short term and
some of them are medium term and some of
them are long term and some of the main
this and some of the main that.
And it isn't necessarily the case that
those desires allow for mutual
fulfillment.
So for example,
maybe you're very interested in pursuing
a sexual relationship with someone,
but you're also very interested in
having a family and some stability in
your life.
Or maybe you're interested in pursuing a
sexual relationship with a whole
sequence of people,
but you're also interested in having a
family of stabilizing your life.
It's not obvious that those desires can
exist in the same universe without
producing what you might think about as
a war.
And some of that might be a
psychological more,
but some of it's also going to be a war
that actually occurs in existence.
Well,
you're fighting through the
contradictory consequences of wanting to
pursue many people and formulate a
stable relationship with one person.
Now,
part of the reason that you want to
think about these sorts of things is
because if you think about them and get
your thoughts and your value system
intelligently and coherently cogently
laid out,
then when you act out that value system
in the world,
you're going to run into less conflict
and less uncertainty and less misery,
and you're going to have a higher
probability of getting what it is that
you want.
But you're also going to have a higher
probability of getting what you want in
a way that allows you to cooperate with
other people without entering into too
much conflict with them.
And so in some sense,
the purpose that you think,
the reason that you think are the
purpose of thinking is so that you can
sort out how you're going to move
forward in the world without having to
directly run headlong into all the
obstacles that you might run into if you
were doing such a thing blindly.
And so then you might yourself,
well,
why would you bother reading philosophy?
The philosophy written by someone who's
great.
And the answer to that is,
is that they can help you think these
things through in a manner that you
would not be capable of doing on your
own.
You know,
because Nisha,
I mean it's,
it's difficult to estimate how
intelligent needs you it was.
But I suspect he was perhaps one in a
billion,
which would put him far beyond the
99.999 percentile.
And there's a massive difference between
the ability of people to think as you
move farther and farther out into the
extremes of intelligence.
And when you have the writings of
someone who's one in a billion,
then you can interact with those
writings in a way that enables you,
if you'll put the time into
benefit from the spectacular.
The fact of that intelligence nature was
a full professor by the time he was 24
at a time when he didn't even have to
write this dissertation.
They just made him a full professor at a
time where that was,
that never happened.
So this is what he has to say.
And the prejudice is a philosopher.
So just the first chapter of that,
oh,
beyond good and evil,
it has gradually become clear to me what
every Greek philosophy up until now has
consistent of namely the confession of
its originator and the species of
involuntary and unconscious
autobiography.
Well,
that's deceptive.
That's a deceptively simple sentence.
Even though it's not a particularly
simple sentence because it,
it stands on a tab.
What people generally assume about the
process of thinking.
You generally think that when you're
thinking,
you're thinking about,
as I mentioned before,
the structure of the objective world
niches is making an entirely different
point here.
And what he's fundamentally doing is
treating the philosopher not as a
rational being,
but as a living being.
And there's a big difference between
being a rational being and being a
living being.
Because if you're living being,
your primary goal is to do whatever it
is that furthers your life.
And if you're a rational being,
then your primary goal is to do whatever
it is that a rational being Mike Duke,
and you could say that the living being
should first and foremost be a rational
being.
And in some sense that's the message of
the,
of the Western enlightenment.
But it's by no means self evident that
that's the case.
And it's certainly not something that
Nietzsche,
Nietzsche doesn't believe that people
are rational beings as certainly not a
primarily and more importantly,
he isn't exactly convinced that they
shouldn't be.
So,
so for example of nature's most famous
maximums is that truth serves life and
that's a very difficult different idea.
Then the purpose of truth say is the
accurate representation of the objective
world.
Those aren't the same thing at all.
Now you could ask,
well,
what does it mean for truth to serve
life?
And if you construed truth that way,
what would truth look like?
And you know,
the mere statement that truths should
serve life doesn't offer you the answers
to those questions.
But
it's the beginning of a different
metaphysics.
And in some sense of metaphysics,
which is say the universe within which a
philosopher might operate a metaphysics
is the initial structure of
presuppositions within which a view of
the world is organized.
One presupposition might be human beings
are rational and that we're attempting
to formulate and improve our sense of
the objective world,
our formulation with the objective
world.
And another would be that you would be
so aren't rational or irrational,
and that we're,
what we're motivated to do is to live
whatever that means and that the purpose
of our thinking and our philosophy
should be to facilitate our living.
And that's Nietzsche's,
that's one of the foundation
blocks of niches,
philosophy.
So he's a moral philosopher,
fundamentally,
because morality is about values and the
values essentially values are,
you could say values are what you aim
for,
but it's more complicated than that.
Values actually constitute the lens
through which you view the world.
So it's partly what you're aiming APP,
but it's also partly your conception of
who you are now and where you are.
And it's also partly your conception of
how you're going to get to where it is
that you want to be.
And it's also partly the psychological
system that you use to parse up the
world so that it reveals to you the
pathway that you can take to get to what
you want.
Value is all of that.
And then it's more than that because you
could say that you have added value
which contains all of that.
But then you can say that you have a set
of values,
which is the arrangement of all about,
and then you can say that you have a set
of values that's the range,
but of all of that,
that you have to arrange with other
people.
And then you could say that you have all
that and you have to arrange it without
a people and you have to arrange it
across different spans of time.
Because what you want today and what you
want next week and what you want next
month are not necessarily at the same
thing.
And one does not necessarily lead into
the other.
So to be a moral philosopher is to
examine how that,
what that system is and how it operates
and how it came about.
Now,
one of the things that nature says is it
has gradually become clear to me what
every Greek philosophy up until now as
consistent up namely the confession of
its originator and a species of
involuntary and unconscious
autobiography.
So his claim fundamentally is that no
matter what the philosopher thinks he's
doing well,
he's reading philosophy.
What he's actually doing is revealing
and articulating his Ba.
And then you might say,
well,
where did that be income from?
And the answer to that is,
well,
partly it's,
you could consider it a biological
function in so far,
is that we have value structures that
are built into us that are the process.
We would say the process of a very long
evolutionary history.
But because you're also a cultural
phenomenon and because the manner in
which you've arranged your values and
your desires has been conditioned to the
last degree by the process of
enculturation that you were subjected to
when you
can fast and an autobiographical manner
and articulate that what you're also
doing is re capitulating the entire
structure of your culture.
It's in you.
And you might say,
well where is it in you and that and
what does it do you mean part of it
means is that you act out in a pattern
of behavior and that pattern of behavior
is like a dance that someone is
manifesting to a symphonic score.
It's unbelievably complicated and it has
its psychological elements.
And some of those are conscious and some
of them aren't.
Some of them are just implicit in
embedded in the way you act and the way
you perceive.
And what the philosopher is attempting
to do is to reveal those to himself and
to articulate them so that the entire
structure can be analyzed.
Well.
So nature's first proposition is that
when a philosopher is thinking that what
he's doing is not thinking,
it's revealing himself and an
autobiographical sense under the guise
of rational thinking,
and so then it becomes something more
like a story.
MMM.
Well,
any governors all about in the first two
phrases,
so that gives you some example,
some indication of what this book is
like
the species of involuntary and
unconscious autobiography.
Well,
that's a more complicated idea too
because you might say,
well,
why would someone be driven in an
involuntary way and an unconscious way
to describe their autobiography?
And
that's a very complicated question.
It might be that one of the reasons that
people value one another is because we
engage in the process of sharing deeply
autobiographical information.
You tell me your story and I tell you my
story and you might say,
well,
why?
Why do we even bother with such things?
And the answer to that as well.
If you can tell me about the pain and
tragedy that you've encountered,
then that gives me a better way of,
that gives me a better vision of the
dangers of the world without actually
having to expose myself to those
dangerous,
except in simulation.
I might feel sorry for you.
I might feel bad about your tragic
experiences,
but I'm not bleeding for them.
And then there's always the possibility
that you'll also tell me how you solved
your problem,
in which case I can either avoid that
problem entirely or if I do encounter,
I can solve it without having to go
through.
Maybe it took you decades to formulate
your solution to that problem and you
can tell me your story and then I have
the information and so that's part of
what human beings are always trading.
That's why we talked to each other.
That's why we can communicate and so
neat.
You would say,
well,
it's,
it's involuntary,
unconscious,
involuntary unconscious.
He's alluding to the fact that that
proclivity is so deeply embedded in
people that desire to,
to make an autobiographical recounting
that,
okay,
it serves as the kind of motivation that
we don't question for doing almost
everything that we do.
So,
you know,
I mean people do such things as a 10
movies in place and they usually do that
happily,
especially if the movie or the play is
of high quality.
And the same thing happens when people
are reading novels.
They're attracted to such things.
They have a built in value and it's very
rarely the case that people will ever
question why it is that they're doing
such things.
In fact,
you see this quite commonly with
students who were first introduced to
the study of literature.
The,
the introduction of the idea that you
should analyze what it is that you're
engaged in when you're reading actually
comes as unwelcome news to most people
who are inclined towards fiction because
they don't want to interfere with the
process of engagement.
You know,
automatic unconscious engagement with
the material by detaching themselves and
having to think about what they're
doing.
So that's why it's an involuntary and
unconscious.
It's,
it's,
it's one of the things within which
thought operates rather than what are
the things on which thought operates.
Then he says the moral or immoral
purpose in which every philosophy has
constituted,
sorry,
the moral or immoral purpose in every
philosophy has constituted the true
vital germ out of which the entire plant
has always grown.
Well,
that's a hell of a thing to say too,
because what Nietzsche is alluding to
there in some senses that
yeah,
the philosopher Kant help and that would
be in some sense also the person who was
recounting their autobiography can't
help but tell you what they're up to,
even though they might not know.
And this is something that you own
because you almost have Carl,
you'll know the site.
They,
psychoanalysts was a great student of
nature and you came to believe that we
all inhabit and stories,
stories,
his stories.
We didn't happen to who were actually
the structures of value within which we
live.
And that those stories essentially had
an ethic or a moral and then you,
you can start thinking about what the
ethics and the morals might be.
And you kind of have some sense of that
because there's,
there's comedic stories and tragic
stories and there's evil characters in
good characters and so forth.
Those are architectural characters.
But part of the point that Nietzsche is
attempting to make here is that the
philosopher is in fact aiming it
something with his life,
with all of his actions.
He might not even know what it is,
but partly what he's doing in his
attempt to philosophize is to articulate
that in reveal it to himself and to
other people.
So then the question becomes,
well,
what is it that the person is up to?
And I would say in some sense that's the
ultimate question.
So neat.
You here in this paragraph,
it is also dealing with the,
with the ultimate question in life,
which might be well to what is your
life?
And,
and you might say,
well,
it's not aimed at anything.
It's it.
I don't know.
I don't seem to have any coherent set of
beliefs.
I don't know what I believe.
I don't believe in anything either.
But that's not the case because if you
didn't believe in anything you couldn't
see,
you have to believe in something to be
able to see because you point your eyes
and things and you can't organize your
vision without having a name.
And so the very act of interacting with
the world presupposes an ethic.
And then all those micro ethics that you
contain within,
you are organized into some sort of
structure,
either badly or well.
And that structure roughly has an aim
and you might know it and you might not,
but that doesn't mean it isn't there.
So,
so what other thing that needs he is
alluding to is that you believe things
whether or not you think you believe
them.
In fact believing them,
unknowing you believe them aren't even
the same thing.
And so the people believe all sorts of
things that they don't know about.
And that partly what they're doing when
they're doing philosophy is to try and
figure out what those things are.
You,
you know,
when you can also ask yourself,
well where did they come from?
Well,
I think partly came from you,
but you,
you're an old thing.
Your physical form is three and a half
billion years old and you're the process
of all that.
All of the death and struggling that
went along the entire course of that
three and a half billion years is you
carry that with you.
And then on top of that inside you is
the consequence of the entire cultural
history of complex life.
That's all inside youtube.
And then on top of that,
some of that's articulated more or less,
some of act without dramatized
represented and fiction and that sort of
thing.
And then some of it's articulated,
but there's way more at the bottom.
Then it is fully articulate and so god
only knows what you're up to.
And then you might say,
well,
who cares?
Well,
the problem with that is that you care
because first of all,
that's the definition of caring.
And second of all that determines that
the,
the way that you will move through your
life and everything that happens to you.
That's good or evil or good or bad,
it's going to be a consequence of the
manifestation of that ethic in the
world.
So,
and now nature is saying something else
too.
When he says the moral or immoral
purpose in whichever,
in the moral or immoral purpose in every
philosophy has constituted the true
vital germ out of which the entire plant
is always grown.
He's saying that the philosopher can't
help but reveal his aim in his writings
and then he's saying something else,
which is that even might be malevolent.
And you know,
modern people aren't very comfortable
with ideas like malevolence because
malevolence is an idea that's related to
evil and modern people think of
themselves as beyond good and evil to
some degree.
They don't believe in the reality of
those concepts.
And of course in this book,
beaches also questioning our,
at least our a priori presuppositions
about what do they need the lar.
But that doesn't mean that he doesn't
believe that they don't exist.
That doesn't mean that he doesn't
Yes,
I guess that's,
I guess that's right.
You know,
this is one of the things I've thought
about when I was thinking about when
I've thought about how Hitler died.
No,
Hitler died.
Hitler committed suicide in a bunker
underneath Berlin when Europe was
inflamed.
And so one
conclusion that a psychoanalytically
minded historian could derive from that
is that's what he wanted,
right?
And then that opens up an entire binder
of vast nest of snakes because one of
the things that you might ask is,
well,
how is it that someone would desire
that?
First of all,
could that even be desired?
Is that actually something that anyone
could even desire?
Then you might ask,
well,
why is it that someone would design
that?
And then the next thing you might ask is
if a human being could desire that and
hit there was a human being then exactly
what does that say about you?
And you might say,
well,
I could never desire is such a thing.
But following along that train of the
argument that we've been laying out,
just like what makes you think you're a
reliable judge of what it is that you're
up to.
So.
Okay,
so now we've unpack three sentences and
we'll continue on with the same
paragraph.
Indeed to understand how the most
abstract metaphysical assertions of a
philosopher have been arrived out.
It is always well and why is to first
ask oneself what morality do they or
does he a mat?
So what the question is,
what's the first enough to,
well,
there's an entire nest of snakes
underneath that sentence,
that sequence of propositions as well.
And one of them is,
well,
what does it mean that people are up to
something?
What does it mean that they're aiming at
something
accordingly?
I do not believe that an impulse to
knowledgist the farther of philosophy
about that,
another impulse here as elsewhere has
only made use of knowledge and mistaken
knowledge as an instrument.
Well,
whoever considers the fundamental
impulses of man with a view to
determining how far they leave here
after this inspiring,
no,
this is why this is going to require it
editing it so complicated to go through
accordingly.
I do not believe that an impulse to
knowledge,
just the farther up philosophy,
but then another impulse here is
elsewhere has only made use of knowledge
and mistaken knowledge as an instrument.
All right,
so let's take that apart accordingly.
I do not believe that an impulse to
knowledge is the farther off philosophy.
So one of the claims,
I suppose this would be an enlightened
human claim,
is that people do have to drive to
knowledge and that that drive is in fact
what underlies the production of such
things as philosophy,
but need to questions that because he's
trying to bring us back to consideration
of the fact that you can't separate the
philosophers mind from the philosophers
being he's first and foremost the living
creature and the,
he's up to something.
And the question is,
what is it that he's up to?
And so you can see the earliest
manifestations in a paragraph like this
of what later developed into
deconstructionists thought and that that
was mostly French continental
philosophers who pursued that particular
line of reasoning.
And it,
it is derived exactly from this kind of
statement by nature.
So for example,
someone like Garrett,
I would say
it doesn't matter what the content of
the text is.
What matters is that the text can be
used as a tool for power.
And then whether the person who wrote
the tax knew it or not,
that's what they were doing and they
were doing it in a way to privilege
themselves above other people.
And that's really,
I would say,
the fundamental deconstructionist plain
and it's a powerful claim.
It's an utterly corrupt claim,
but it's a really powerful claim and
it's related directly to the sorts of
things that need you was referring to in
this paragraph.
What is it that the person is truly up
to?
Now the problem with the
deconstructionist claim is that it's an,
it's an open invitation,
cynicism to thoughtless citizens.
I can just make the presupposition that
whatever it is that you're telling me,
you're you,
you're telling me merely to dominate
regardless of what it is that you claim
to be doing.
Well,
the problem with that approach is that
it's predicated on the implicit
assumption that the only value that
people actually have is the value is the
desire to dominate.
And of course that's a purely like that
could be the case.
And I also think that it's even
reasonable to posit that to some degree
that it is the case.
But to take that from a contributing
factor and to make that the highest God
because that's essentially what the
deconstructionists are doing.
Those are entirely different things and
you have to be aware of people who
take a single causal element and
elevated to the stature of single
comprehensive cause.
You know,
it's more reasonable to assume that
people are complex in their motivation.
So many different strands of biological
and cultural motivation are in some
sense primary.
And then what happens is that they come
together to weave the kind of tapestry
rather than to make the automatic
assumption that you can reduce the
entire set of human motivations to a
single principle like that power.
Now you know,
I would say niche is also responsible to
some degree for the deconstructionist
claim that it's power.
Because one of his most famous
utterances was that the fundamental
motivating force in life is the will to
power.
But he wasn't so much because nature is
a subtle thinker.
He wasn't so much attempting to reduce
human motivation to power.
He was attempting to redefine what it
was that we conceptualize downs power.
Whereas that isn't what the
deconstructionists circling and all.
Because fundamentally they're Marxists
and they believe that you know who they
is ensconced themselves within an
economic viewpoint where within a
philosophical viewpoint where economics
is paramount and where all that matters
is power construed as socioeconomic
domination fundamental,
you know,
and that's in turn is embedded in
metaphysics.
That's even deeper,
which is a metaphysics that presume that
people are fundamentally materialists
and all of those things are quick in a
lot of those things are highly
questionable.
So I'm going to skip ahead a little bit
of the paragraph.
When Nietzsche talks about
the motivations of,
you would consider them
people who were working in the middle
ranks of bureaucracies,
whether they're scientific or otherwise.
So they're in some sense acting as cogs
in a particular machine.
And so that's what he's describing here.
He says
in the case of scholars or in the case
of really scientific men,
it may be there may really be such a
thing as an impulse to knowledge,
some kind of small independent clockwork
which when well wellmed out works away
industriously to that end without the
rest of the scholarly impulses taking
any material park there in the actual
interests of the scholar therefore are
generally in quite another direction.
It is the family or in moneymaking more
in politics.
It is in fact almost indifferent at what
point of research his little machine is
place and whether the hopefully young
worker becomes a good fill.
Ologist someone who studied the origin
of words,
a mushroom specialist or a chemist.
He's not characterized becoming this by
this.
He's not characterized by becoming this
or that
niches point.
There are fundamentally is that even
when you do analyze people who in whom
the the wheel to knowledge might
actually be operative,
even though he wouldn't be willing to
granted the status of highest motivating
power that even in those people where
that Wilton all does exist,
the probability that that is in turn
subordinated to some other principle
that's higher than the value hierarchy
is very,
very high.
And it's hard to tell exactly what that
additional principle might be,
but he points out such things as well.
Maybe they're primarily interested in
serving the interests of their family or
they're primarily interested in making
money or maybe they're primarily
interested in status and maybe they're
interested in status status becomes it
because it makes them more sexually
attractive and that sort of thing.
So,
but,
uh,
the question of what is it that's
lurking in the background is always
paramount.
So
there
detour in this particular paragraph,
okay,
whoever considers the fundamental
impulses of man with a view to
determining how far they may have here
acted as inspiring Jenai
or his demons will find that they have
all practice philosophy at one time or
another.
And that each of them would have been
only too glad to look upon itself as the
ultimate end of existence and the
legitimate lord over all of the other
impulses.
That's another like the beyond good and
evil.
To think of it as a book is a really
foolish
framework.
You know,
cause this is what a book is.
When people think about a book,
you know,
it's like a material entity.
It's,
it's eight inches high and six inches
wide and two inches thick and weighs a
pound and it's made out of paper and
it's between two,
two covers.
You know?
And that's a materialist.
That's the eight priority,
sort of axiomatic view of book.
Nature's beyond good and evil isn't a
book at all.
It's a series of bombs and each sentence
is a ball.
And each sentence blows things up that
people don't even know exist.
And so one of the things that with this
sentence,
for example,
here's how he's conceptualizing human
being.
So the first thing he talks about is
that the FA,
there are fundamental impulses that
human beings,
okay,
so that begs a question.
Well,
what do you mean by impulse and what do
you mean by fundamental?
And both of those are extraordinarily
complicated problems.
So an impulse,
you can think of an impulse as it drive.
You could think about it as a biological
instinct.
They could think about it as a name or a
goal.
You could think about it as an act of
will.
Like there's,
there's endless questions that that,
hang off that question.
But we could start with the idea that we
perhaps can't define it,
but we are willing to go with the
proposition that people do have the
impulses.
And I think maybe that's manifest to you
more.
Most particularly when you're attempting
to do something voluntarily and
something in voluntarily interferes with
that.
You know,
so maybe you're sitting down to to try
to get some work done in the work is not
of any particular intrinsic interest but
you regarded as necessary,
you know,
necessary element in some higher order
scheme.
And so you're attempting to organize
yourself so you will in fact concentrate
on that particular relatively mundane
activity.
But what you find when you sit down to
actually engage in that is you can't do
it.
You have to go do the dishes or you have
to clean under the bed,
or you have to have a sexual fantasy or
you or,
or there's some other thing that you
could do that's useful but that you
wouldn't normally do,
that you'll go do instead.
Or that you fall asleep or that you get
hungry or like there's an endless number
of,
let's call them impulses that might
arise to interfere with your conscious
movement forward.
Well,
exactly.
What are those things?
While nature certainly conceptualizes
the human being as a place where those
things live,
and he does mean live too because it
wouldn't refer it to the misdeed demons
are or Jeanie's without introducing the
metaphor conception of something that
lives.
And so partly what needs to reveals in
no sentences is that he conceptualized
as a human being as the dwelling place
of spirits.
And
some of them are Gv,
let's say that's the root word of
genius.
That's the terribly powerful thing that
exists in the terribly small
compartment,
right,
that you have to call forth.
And some of them are demons and demons
are things that have their own
autonomous will and the generally aren't
aiming for the good.
So then,
so those are all things need.
She just lays out as implicit parts of
the sentence.
So we activates all those ideas,
whether you know it or not,
in your mind,
to the degree that you processed the
sentence.
And those things start to take on a life
of a row of their own,
those ideas.
So
then he adds another dimension of
complexity to that by saying,
well,
you're full of demons and,
and,
and Jeannie's and they're all doing
their own thing,
whatever that happens to be.
But each of them,
if left to their own devices,
would attempt to remake the entire world
in there
form.
And so I thought of this from,
from a narrative point of view or from a
symbolic point of view in,
in,
uh,
in old stories and folktales and
fairytales,
you often have a,
um,
cyclops
one night giants and there's a sexual
connotation to that which is,
which is apropos that the psychoanalysts
would,
would certainly point out.
But the one idea is that this thing is
gigantic and wants one thing.
And so that's another way that Nietzsche
is conceptualizing the fundamental
structure of the human psyche.
It's a dwelling place full of one I
giants.
And they're constantly,
while one thing,
one way of looking at is they're
constantly at war.
One of them wants to be the largest one.
I giant and dominate everything else.
Then one of the things that,
so in each,
it takes that argument further and he
says,
not only is this always happening in
human beings,
but then if you look at philosophy,
what it is,
is it's a continual revelation of the
attempt of some singular minded psychic
monster psychological monster to
dominate the entire psychological
structure that are for the entire
cultural structure.
And therefore the entire world.
And then you can,
you can see in that the entire religious
structure struggle of mankind to take
this vast polytheistic vision of reality
and to organize it into some sort of
monotheistic,
an integrated structure,
which you could also consider
indistinguishable from the civilizing,
the impulse that operates in human
beings to become civilized.
Because on the one it might be a
terrible thing that one,
one eyed monster emerge as to attempt to
dominate all the others.
But then on the other hand,
there's no difference between that and
organizing something because to organize
something is to bring it all into a
hierarchical structure with some sort of
singular value at the forefront.
And then the question might be,
well,
what should that singular value b and
then neat you would.
That ties the whole argument back into
the first sentences that he wrote at the
beginning of the paragraph,
which is,
well,
what is it that the philosopher is up
to?
What is the force that he serving?
What is that unifying impulse?
That's another way of looking at it.
If there's a unifying impulse and he's
not only fallen prey to some internal
email,
if there's a unifying impulse to bring
all of this together into some sort of
functional structure,
what exactly might that look like?
For every impulse is imperious.
And as such attempts to philosophize,
that's part of that sort of niches idea
of will to power in in its nascent form.
All of these unconscious entities that
inhabit the human psyche are all alive
and they're trying to live.
They're trying to,
they're trying to climb up the dominance
hierarchy and dominate because of course
that's partly what lights does.
Because let's say from an evolutionary
perspective,
and this is probably more true for males
because there were less
effective in their attempts to replicate
the distinction between climbing up a
dominance hard keep,
whatever that might happen to be.
And success is,
there may be no distinction at all.
And then you might say,
well that just shows,
but there's nothing but willpower.
But
that still doesn't answer one of the
most fundamental questions is that power
in relationship to what?
Cause that's the question.
Okay.
So you can shut that off.